whoa
let's save me MJ ushering in 20 years of
legendary Spider-Man no way home has
been a nostalgic roller coaster for us
watching but you think we were emotional
how about everyone on set stick around
for what it was really like for the cast
of Spider-Man no way home on set it's
okay should we do the kiss
excuse me number one which came first
the hero or the villain we don't know
but we do know Spider-Man no way home
brought us triple the Spidey and triple
the trouble three of our favorite
villains feature in this installment
Electro Dr Octopus and of course Green
Goblin which one is the most trouble
though
number two Spider-Man no way home had
more spider men which meant three times
more actors on wires for those scenes
not only did this mean more coordination
for the stunts but director John Watts
needed to work with the team to
establish distinct movement styles for
each Spider-Man you never lose sight of
the fact that it's Peter Parker
underneath that costume and that was
really important to me number three
everybody was dancing Spider-Man no way
home actor Zendaya Tells A Tale of one
of the most memorable days on set and it
wasn't even a part of the script Green
Goblin dancing we can't tell if this is
a nightmare or a dream come true number
four one of the highest numbers of
actors on wires we've seen in a long
time anyone remember Moonraker
especially given that the force of
gravity is present for most of the story
this seems to us like it would have been
a logistical nightmare but it was no
problem for this team of inspired
professional a little more planning and
a little more rehearsal kept this cast
floating along smoothly and safely
scream I don't really you don't know
number five
with all the air time the actors were
getting on the set of Spider-Man no way
home came even more rehearsal time and
with several of these actors doing most
of their own stunts that could really
start to add up Tom Holland Spider-Man
or spider monkey number six you want to
know what's inside tempting we know we
do too as a resource to help the actors
breathe more life into the world of
Spider-Man no way home director John
Watts gave them permission to improvise
and ad-lib lines during scenes that was
pretty cool he would later discover that
by lifting the confines of the script
just a little bit he had unleashed the
playfulness of this pack of stars and
sometimes that must have felt like
herding kittens you have been listening
ever since you stepped on my hose I did
I didn't maybe it's broken number seven
putting together a movie full of stunts
is a physically demanding undertaking
but a day on the set of Spider-Man no
way home wasn't all hard work and with a
big cast of Big characters come some big
tricksters with big Shenanigans imagine
trying to tell a room full of these
stars to get back to work number eight
bloopers no scripted wait no blooper
with tricksters and tricks all over this
set sometimes it was hard to tell
whether a bit was a blooper or was in
fact scripted here's one moment of many
what do you think blooper or scripted
it's actually a mix of both I feel like
also for myself I want to also be
surprised number nine while it certainly
wasn't a blooper it probably wasn't
scripted either Spider-Man actor Andrew
Garfield was riding the emotional roller
coaster of Spider-Man no way home when
he added his own feeling to a scene by
letting the other spideys know just how
he really felt I love you guys
number 10. Andrew Garfield wasn't the
only one on set adding his own Flair In
the Heat of the Moment several of the
other Spider-Man no way home actors were
caught adding a little extra spice that
might not line up so well with spidey's
family-friendly values sorry
number 11 wait were those Clues what's
he trying to tell us with the lines of
bloopers and script being blurred on The
Daily could it be possible that Spidey
revealed new unheard of superheroes
there's a dinosaur man there's an
octopus man and then there's this old
man or could it just be actor Tom
Holland playing a trick on Marissa Tomei
you'll have to decide for yourself with
this one
[Music]
number 12 High highs means lower lows
the bonds made between members of the
cast of Spider-Man no way home saw no
exception when it came Time to Say
Goodbye it was hard to see each other go
every spider person knows webs go up and
webs come down you know where to find us
number 13 another day another beating
Spider-Man no way home actor Tom Holland
knows that life as a superhero is no
walk in the park
if he didn't already know the intense
fight scenes with the Spidey villains
served as a Stern teacher with great
power often comes a great pummeling
can't jump into the poses like I used to
when I was 19. but uh but no I'll be all
right number 14. are we spider or are we
dancer while actor Tom Holland might
have taken a daily beating on the set of
Spider-Man no way home you could say he
can't stop won't stop working till he
gets the shot Tom gave every day
everything he had left it all on the
dance floor and always showed up the
next day feeling fresh it was pretty
typical
a typical process it just was on a much
grander scale number 15 posing time one
last call for webs on walls so finish
your fight scenes and
you get the idea Spider-Man no way home
has more than what we've seen from
spidey's world before with these
exciting additions comes exciting
reveals looks like these actors had just
as much fun during their promo shots as
they did on set and when all on set is
done it's posing time you don't have to
go home but you can't pose here number
16 if she wants it she's got it not only
did she play a pivotal role in Spidey
story but Spider-Man no way home actor
Zendaya was also diving deep into the
world of directing I was coming in every
day on set to watch John work spending
much of her time off volunteering on set
and shadowing director John Watts we are
sure Spider-Man would appreciate her
taking a leap of faith and really taking
a swing at it seems great and lovely and
shared so much with me number 17. it's
strange but oh so cool Spider-Man no way
home showed us vision of timelines
Spider-Man villains and worlds all
together and of course such a unique
moment in the Multiverse could only be
facilitated by none other than Dr
Strange himself it was it was it was
extraordinary it really was
extraordinary the on-screen Adventure
took us inside the sanctum sanctorium
which was thrilling itself but the
behind the scenes experience was an
adventure for the actors as well once in
the longer you go on doing that the more
dangerous it becomes the ever-changing
weather and temperature conditions on
the set of the sanctum sanctorium proved
to be a perfect setting for creating
whole new blooper reel moments with some
of our favorite actors slipping up and
slipping around Seal's tight that's
right he did probably not what you
thought working on set would be like
right did you imagine it would have been
as strange or wonderful as this we've
picked our favorite moments now let us
know which day on set would you have
loved to be there for